please okay now I actually I'm one of
you it off move office method but not
quite okay
part of the reason why this is so
confusing okay is because I have one two
three regions there's a way to cut it
down to two
isn't anyone tell me where did the three
regions come from what one region one
regions the absolute value right the
other region came from the fact that I
had to multiply by its X and multiply by
X means like which way do you go and so
on okay so to get away from that dog
alone
this is method two okay I'm still gonna
solve it by regions but this time I'm
gonna multiply by X win
okay now why is multiplying by x squared
a better idea than multiplying by x
squared is always positive so I don't
need to worry about which direction me
inequality goes I just have to worry
about this absolute value okay but it
lends its own problems okay so I've
given up all of this how can we make
cases better right so when you want to
plug through by x squared what happens
you're gonna get an X on this side right
because x squared times X that absolute
value is still there and then you're
gonna get next on the other side sorry
an x squared now here's why most of my
makes quits but better but it's better
because now I don't have to worry about
the judge human equality but it's
because never saw quadratic okay
but it's not that bad a quadratic so
let's go ahead in order to actually
expand this out then I have to introduce
cases because it's like well what kind
of helps and I do I have so case one
what happens tonight I've got a stack of
minus sign okay so I'm gonna get this so
down to your the case by the way the
reason why I always set up all my cases
first okay is because then I can think
okay the difference in this case in this
case is clear in my mind rather than
during this case solve it and therefore
well my other case what's it doing okay
so don't be distracted to do cases
although there may be guarantees about
the presents all right okay this means
there's no negative on the front so I'll
get this okay now sit up my cases let's
song okay it does tend to turn out to be
quite simple alright so here I've got
minus 3x squared plus X less than 2x
sweat okay so let's see here subtract 2x
squared so X minus 5x of squared so
that's X outside of one minus 5x is that
okay yes now what does this guy look
like this is a parabola is a concave up
or down okay it's on cable down right so
the roots are 0 and that says smoothie
doesn't it okay so 0 v now I want it to
be less than 0
yes so this part okay and this part okay
and this part the minimum is busted okay
what I've got to combine my conclusion
with my case right so X is less than a
third somewhere over here right so that
means what am I concluded out of this I
run out of space
okay what this leads to is X is less
than zero
Oh between a fifth and a third that
makes sense
you see how I've gotten that out of
their question it's the same one
trust me you start this case unless you
screw up the algebra it's the same case
okay yeah trust me why go home and do it
and you see he's thank you did any
different problems yes in that case okay
three x squared squared okay take the x
squared so x squared again this is a
problem but it's concave right and it's
roots are at 0 & 1 now I want the parts
that are less than 0 yes
so that's these parts on here 0 & 1 but
I have to include my case and my
conclusion together right so I want to
be greater than the third where's a
third on this it's like they're right so
now I've ruled out that part because
it's not greater than 13 so from case 2
what I've got is I'm between the 3rd and
1 right which takes me back to where I
got from my first method okay X is less
than zero that's fine okay a 5th to a
third test x equals 1/3 and verify
two more okay the reason why I do not
need to test a fifth or one is because
the way I arrived at those numbers was
by algebra but I have to test a third
because I've arbitrarily taken out a
third as a valid because look I didn't
even test it unless in the third or rent
of a third and I just forgot about a
third to make my cases unambiguous right